remembering a fallen trooper micah may
today the southern nevada community will
hold a candlelight vigil
to honor the fallen hero hector mejia
live in the northwest valley with
details about tonight's remembrance
event
hector taylor bianca and everyone is
invited to attend tonight here hosted by
the injured police officers fund
you know all morning we've been showing
you uh different memorials here spread
across the park here at the police
memorial park this one for example
honors those peace officers who have
died over the decades who gave their
lives in the line of duty
one of them dates back to 1928
and tonight's vigil honoring trooper
micah may is set for 6 pm here near
cheyenne and grand canyon drive
new footage shows the wild car chase
that eventually led to
nhp trooper mika mae's death last week
helicopter video shows carjacking
suspect douglas claiborne driving
erratically on i-15 and also on the
surrounding streets
metro police say he intentionally hit
trooper may
as may placed stop sticks on i-15 near
the charleston off-ramp
there you hear that police video there a
trooper may crashed through the
windshield when he was hit
troopers had to ram the car to stop
claiborne's rampage
while the suspect was shot and killed on
the scene and since this tragic incident
we've seen an outpouring of love and
support
for the trooper's family on behalf of
trooper micah may's family
and the dps family we would like to
thank the kind people of our las vegas
community
it's been really tough for the law
enforcement community if you'd like to
help trooper mays family you can donate
money to them through the injured police
officers fund
we have a link already available on
eightnewsnow.com and again back out here
the vigil is set for 6 pm tonight it
will be a day of mourning for law
enforcement agencies all across the
valley here
and this is set for 6 p.m here at the
police memorial park near cheyenne
and grand canyon drive reporting live in
the northwest dr mejia
8 news now